ghost lara c'è un video per te o di
punta non ti strusciare su di loro no ma
guarda non voglio cadere al volgare
c'è pure se stesso al culo non so
portatela letto favo prima aspetta che
ti faccio vedere io adesso è rega ha
acceso la fiamma non ha idea di cosa lì
con vero io no raga io l'ho sul mondo
come un mobile dell'ikea lara cosa pezzi
di quello che hai visto schifo
francamente sono schifata non ci sono
lacrime non c'è niente se non rabbia da
fare schifo
lara o un altro video per te
calcolando che lei ha problemi proprio
ai denti di chiusura ma l'occasione e
roba varia ma che cazzo dici
le ho detto andiamo da dentista
valutiamo usa la scusa che i dentisti
non è biagio
la scusa 4.000 euro dove li tirò fuori
dal tuo culo a un certo punto mi chiedo
io voglio passare tutta la vita con una
che si blocca e non risolve i problemi
mi stai sul cazzo ci sono delle cose che
caratterialmente non posso accettare ma
vai a cagare no vabbè ma vi rendete
conto lega cioè io apro come una merda
certo che cos'è il cervello un criceto è
venuto qua per dimostrarmi che ha fatto
delle stronzate e cosa fai schifo
maicol c'è un video per te
e la vita continua anche senza di lui
riccardo ci troviamo al falò di
confronto prima del previsto perché
perché ci sono stati alcuni
atteggiamenti che mai avrei pensato di
vedere perché mi sembra di averle dato
tante dimostrazioni e non lo so mi
sembra di aver perso qualcosa
riccardo tu come pensi di esserti
comportato benissimo benissimo non bene
rispettoso nei confronti della donna che
amo ok riccardo noi abbiamo comunicato
aida che tu hai richiesto il fallo di
confronto
vediamo se ed ha accettato i ricordi
quello che ci eravamo detti prima di
entrare vero se e cosa è successo allora
lo chiedo a te riccardo lo chiedi a me
non rispettato ma se fai provolone
ricordo con tutte ha aumentato ancora di
più la mia gelosia e tu che vai a
giocare a nascondino con quello la
spiegazione e questa mi sono nascosta a
nascondino punto quando ci siamo
conosciuti sapevo che volevo incontrare
la donna della mia vita per una famiglia
perché era quello che desideravo poi ha
avuto il mod e ida e samuel
[Musica]
ti sei mai ti amo ti amo anch'io ricordo
voglio prendermi cura di entrambi te lo
giuro sia movida non minacciare non mi
lascia raffaela come va va
non lo so va bene va male piango rito
non lo so raffaela o un video per te
ballerino e cantante è diventata
come la guarda mamma mia
ma [ __ ] un cd che non lo capisco e
non mi vuoi
hai paura perché sto male
adesso mi piangere un mese ma vattene e
questo quello che provo raffaela forse
c'è un video che può ulteriormente
chiarirti le idee
maria questa cena morata si sono
innamorati ragazze ma rossa the press
stronzo visto uccide dimagrire con
dentro stavo avanza tutti i giorni dalla
mattina alla sera
solo quando già la affiancherà
tranquilla coincidevano innamorati
allora come si è visto francesco ha
buttato tutte le colpe addosso a me io
da donna mi sono presa le colpe e ho
detto ha ragione però vorrei anche che
lui insomma capisce quali sono stati i
suoi errori
cioè se deve essere solo uno
scaricabarile non mi sembra corretto e
poi deve capire lui cosa vuole e
soprattutto me lo devi dire se non mi
ama più che me lo dica e cioè fili ami
non manca niente proprio niente
i problemi si risolvono in due se non si
ha la voglia uno da una parte e
dall'altra è buona voglio confronto
stasera
[Musica]
ora